so there's an snl skit
with will ferrell that he wrote
about uh don't fear the reaper
where
as bruce dickinson is the producer i
always think about you when i see that
skit i don't know why people should
definitely watch it and he
demands more cowbell into the mix
and uh the whole band is how i imagine
people interact with you the whole band
is really impressed like we get to work
with the great bruce dickinson
and then it's played by christopher
walken and he says
like fellas fellas i uh
i put on my pants one leg at a time just
like the rest of you
but once my pants are on i make gold
records
and i just
and then he and then the whole skit
continues and he wants to add more and
more cowbell and will ferrell said he
wrote that skit because he always heard
the song don't fear the reaper and
there's a distant cowbell it's very
light in the mix and he's like i wonder
what
that the story of that cowbell is like
if we just look at that one layer who's
that guy that was in there
uh so is that basically exactly how your
life is is bruce dickinson from the
cowbo
i don't know if you've seen that skit
uh
i don't think it's like that it's not
okay all right
i'm just gonna pretend that
you